so
what was the award that you were giving
the award was for best artist
and the actual winner was the white
stripes no the actual winner was
coldplay
but um nick dunlap got the idea to like
say like
um it was when like um everyone was mad
at metallica or something like for for
for um busting napster yeah napster
stuff
in in um so he's like oh what if you say
it's for metallica but then
and then they come up and then be like
oh sit no it's not you guys sit down
um it's coldplay and then they're all
like oh the only band that's actually
here is the white stripes and so then
nick as nick and i was like i really
like the white stripes i don't want to
do that to them and then
as we drank a little bit you know nick
nick basically convinced me to do it you
know i don't blame him i did it but
you know so it was time to give out the
award and he opened up the envelope and
had said coldplay open up the envelope i
say and the winner is the white stripes
and they played that night and
everything which was it was awesome and
i was into the white stripes like
before they were big i saw them play at
little places like i was hardcore into
them
like um from way before and in them
you know and then so i actually gave
everyone time to cheer for them
and like they walked halfway through the
stage and stuff and then i'm like
just kidding it's coldplay oh god oh
[ __ ]
yeah i felt i immediately felt so bad
but
lifelong regret was that he didn't just
stick to his guns and give the [ __ ]
thing
have you ran into them since the thing
is i didn't even think about that then i
should have just given it to them
that would have been such a baller move
to be like now
it didn't even come up until like weeks
later like oh
she was giving the award to them like
right oh god and
so i ran into meg white later that night
you know
i was like i was like oh i'm so sorry um
you know
and her her like security guy wanted to
like fight me and
yeah i knew like or he was he didn't
like me
but um but meg was super cool i ended up
talking to her for like hours
and um jack wasn't there but um i i
apologize so
much and we had a great conversation got
along famously but um
she was super cool and but she's like it
wouldn't have been a big deal but
we were halfway to the stage
that's so gnarly dude but basically i
did that because i didn't belong there
like i was always like like you know i
didn't like the mainstream stuff like i
was like
um you know whatever you know
who cares is stupid awards you know if
the white stripes guy
that guy was all about being like punk
rock you know like and he later became
pretty mainstream himself i guess but
you know they're rad
and it was that was mean of me to do
but i should have given them the award
so i would like if they
i don't know if they listen to your
podcast but if they do
um i i would like them to know that that
i wish i would have given them the award
and they were the best band of the year
in my eyes
yeah for sure it's shocking that they
didn't have the award to begin with
i know it is it really is
yeah dude